foreign
you don't do that
you and my world now
and you're lucky you ain't here oh but I
slick where she was I'm joking I'm
joking I am team Keep Your Hands to
Yourself
[Music]
Miss Debbie's son Julian confronts Usama
over his behavior toward his mother and
for allegedly using her for a green card
I'm a cop I can sniff out both miles
away and you're the biggest bull I've
ever seen my entire life go to the
dentist and get yourself fixed up man
you said that right Gabe we've got a lot
to talk about let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's Malicia to all
the mothers out there I hope you enjoyed
your mother's day also I know Mother's
Day isn't easy for everyone so if it's a
tough time for you just know you are
included in this Mother's Day love I'm
sending out and I want to give a special
shout out to my mom we had a lovely time
this weekend and now back to our show
okay this episode was a little different
they had the regular season finale
attached to the first part of the
tell-all now when it comes to the season
finales takeaways Gabe and Isabelle got
married in a heartfelt ceremony
yay congrats to them and it's official
Mahmoud is planning on moving to the U.S
to try life out here with Nicole
good luck so now that that's out of the
way let's get into what we came here for
I can't believe we made it
yes that's Miss Debbie honey giving full
queen bee Vibes at the sell-off Miss
Debbie is all about accessories y'all
Wade we have to take a moment to look at
this look she comes in Rocking a hot
pink fur with a pink sparkly little
dress underneath and these lime green
cowgirl boots with the matching pink fan
all I want to know is who styled her or
did she style herself that's something I
have to ask have you two been in touch
since you left each other
Osama has tried to communicate with me
once the tell-out starts she and Usama
are the first ones in the hot seat Usama
appearing virtually from Morocco looking
like one of my cousins with this fade
and goatee
it looks nice though anyway Osama
reveals that after he and Debbie broke
up and she left Morocco he tried calling
her thousands of times but she didn't
answer yes that is what I want to hear
she is staying strong moving off that
heartbreak momentum that should be the
name of the song Heartbreak momentum oh
yeah and Debbie you weren't picking up
that phone because
it was just too difficult for me to wrap
my head around what went on in Morocco
and you know I needed to heal myself and
press a reset button they start to
discuss the moment this season when
Usama told Debbie she needs to take him
to the United States so he can get a
green card or else they are over and
surprisingly there was one cast member
who didn't think Usama was wrong for
that
we're not non-profitsitation
foreign
so you're saying Usama success is more
important than Debbie living the life
she wants
basically she should sacrifice her
desires to help this young man thrive
when Osama doesn't even want to get a
job where he is now in Morocco but
that's the conversation we'll get to
later so Osama
were you really in love with Debbie
yeah I loved her but now I don't love
her
because she won't let you come you come
Erica because like that's the reason you
don't love her he doesn't know what love
means he just doesn't know Sean goes on
to ask Usama if he doesn't love her why
was he calling her thousands of times
and his answer is flat out ridiculous
just I mean to explain to her that
I mean like we have to end this and uh
it was already oh
there goes Julian I'm a fan he takes
care of his mama just I mean to explain
to her that
I mean like we have to end this and uh
like there is no more future for us just
to make things clear
I mean things were clear before you
tried to make the phone calls
five minutes
who makes phone calls to tell somebody
it's over when they're not taking your
calls
um can do this well Osama that makes you
look a little different
to say the least
fast forward my mood ends up giving his
honest two cents on Debbie and usama's
relationship I feel like he wants
something from here because like how old
are you
I'm 24. 24 so as he 24 and she I don't
know how she all but like she looks so
old in him
it's too much the edge between them
but the souls have no age
this is the point all right let's
finally hear what Debbie's son has to
say to Sama about how he treated his
mother
let's bring him out here please welcome
Julian
Gabe is all of us please welcome Julian
boy let me tell you something
you are so full
you mess with somebody's mama you don't
do that
you and my world there Julian came out
there with that southern cop Voice on
it had me a little shook
boy let me tell you something and Usama
took a nice big gulp this is probably
one of the only moments he's glad he's
not in the states
you're lucky you ain't here
yeah
Julian didn't even wait until he got you
his seat to say something to Usama he
stopped in the middle of the carpet did
someone give me a TV Remote turn it off
oh my gosh I
I love you yeah I just love you okay Jen
was like that was hot
might be time to ditch the pretty boys
gin get you a country boy who loves his
mama
and who was out here saving baby deers
yes apparently Julian saved a baby deer
the other day while he was on duty as a
cop go check out his Instagram post his
caption was sweet this needs to be over
with in his stalker ways he better not
be calling no more he better not be
texting 60 texts in what two hours
psychopath
I gave out the best reactions throughout
the tell-all
60 texts in what two hours
psychopath
same oh I love you who does that
Osama you told us you were calling her
multiple times to end the relationship
did you send Debbie a text that said I
love you
I can't remember
oh now he wants to pull a big head I may
have I don't I don't remember he's lying
the whole time I was back there he was
lying you know I'm a cop I can sniff out
both miles away and you're the biggest
bull I've ever seen my entire life
you're lucky my mom even gave you a
second of her life
okay Doug
okay dog that was unexpected and he said
it's so proper to where I'm over here
thinking is he really trying to call him
a dog I can sniff out both miles away
and you're the biggest bull I've ever
seen my entire life okay we know who
someone was a cat person go to the
dentist and get yourself fixed up man
trying to use people come over for green
cards
quit praying off of elderly women that
look like they're they're vulnerable get
a job yes let's talk about the job Osama
responds by saying he will not get a job
because quote he's a poet and he will
die for his dream
he should have just said he doesn't want
to work which is why I guess he needed
Debbie so he can eat
she revealed that over the course of
their three-year relationship she sent
him two to three thousand dollars and
paid for groceries and day-to-day living
which is chump change Gabe tries to help
Usama out by suggesting he sell his art
to tourists to make money and dusama
responds by saying this I need someone
to stand by punchings
I mean I'm not selling underwears or
something I'm selling something valuable
for me was that shade toward Gabe maybe
I'm reaching I'm saying something
valuable for me still in to people who
understand my art not someone who want
to buy attention
it doesn't make any sense you're
limiting yourself it doesn't make sense
for you because you are not obnoxious
and you can't understand this kind of
things baby understand me are there a
lot of artists who leave their pieces up
to their clients interpretation
maybe Osama is scared of what I don't
know but he's coming up with all the
excuses in the world not to put the work
behind his dream I know you're an artist
and you're sensitive about your ish but
circumstances aren't going to always be
ideal at first
at this moment what it's really sounding
like and hopefully this doesn't come off
too harsh I don't want to be too rough
on Usama but it's sounding like
he wants the handout put your big boy
pants on go get a job do what you can
you know you don't stop and say oh I'm
just going to paint pictures and do
poetry the world takes sweat Blood and
Tears
you better motivate Julian
the conversation switches gears to if
Usama was actually attracted to 67 year
old Debbie did you ever have a physical
attraction to her and he claims he was
why does Debbie look worried we had some
wonderful evenings together enjoyed wine
and cheese and Fine Food and yes he
tried to get Amorous with me wait try to
get amorous
but that's normal you know Barry White
time he wanted to try to get Barry White
time with you right
[Music]
she tried
he tried white time Miss Debbie says I'm
a lady and I'm not about to speak in
detail about my sex life
I respect it all that was said basically
Echoes what she told me back in March
he's a red-blooded man it's like he's
tried but when I say no guess what he
respects me Debbie and osama's time in
the hot seat raps with Sean asking
Debbie if she would continue to
communicate with Usama after the
tell-off and I liked what she was going
with it at first he'd have to
move a mountain for me to respond to him
until she clarified you know he could
start by sending me an airline ticket oh
hell oh hell no Miss Debbie better be
saying that because she knows he can't
afford it he could start by sending me
an airline ticket no see no see that's
what I'm talking about that's exactly
what I'm talking about cut the cord
well it's a lot easier to cut after you
know him showing his true colors there
okay Osama are you open to moving a
mountain to get Debbie back
no I don't think so yeah we'll see text
messages in about three days
at this point the cast takes a break and
during it
Debbie tries to hook Julian
Julian last time we checked she and
Rishi are no longer together
guess what Julian this is between you
and me and the fence post what didn't
you think Jen was kind of cute and nice
do you think she kind of was like
batting her eyes at you a little bit
flashback
yep I think she's a cool person why you
put me on a spot like that oh he's
blushing not putting you on no spot I'm
just saying that hey you know her dude
is kind of like
he's kind of acts like Osama a little
bit dang Rishi she is coming for you but
you got my number you can give it to her
okay ooh do y'all ship Jin and Julian
Jen and Julian that has a ring to it or
do you think of them let me know in the
comments oh yeah Gabe and my mood got
into it this episode because Gabe
confronted him about quote forcing
Nicole to dress a certain way it got so
bad my mood couldn't contain himself he
looked like he was about to explode so
he stormed off camera
and during next week's tell-all we see
the aftermath of that back and forth so
what this happened today is like he go
upstairs
I'm sorry honey I can't control what
comes out of the mouths of other people
but we have to come together
[Music]
where are you my love I'm the camera now
I want to see this ass
he's so mad he's cursing all over the
place and at this point specifically I
was trying to figure out what foul
language he was using what I'm going to
say
I was counting the Dodge trying to use
context clues and everything
all right 90 day fans fam that was
interesting make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
foreign